by the way osama bin laden's family
abandoned their belarus state list for
28 million dollars have you guys seen
this house
pull up this house by the way if you
would have thought a matter of fact
before you pull it up i got a question
for you
if you would have thought the name osama
bin laden and in a state in bel air
what color would you guess this house
wouldn't be
white white what color would you say
there's no way in the world
osama bin laden barbara estate and the
color is
pink pull up the house the sister house
type in osama bin laden house biller
okay
oh my gosh you interviewed his niece i
did not know her matter of fact we were
texting yesterday yes she's work shoes
kai in the future you can just have
these tabs ready and go right to them
i'm
just saying right there click on that
click on that he normally does but this
one
john cougar oh by the way shout out to
kai's new haircut has anyone checked
this out that's
he's too good looking can you control
and make it bigger kai it's important
for people to see what this house looks
like
there it is pink i was right that's a 28
million dollar house 20 million dollar
house sean cougar if you've got to be a
holdbacker if you're
thinking about it it's uh adam not a bad
idea for you looks like the bomb i'm
good in california
but you know as i started reading this
story i'm like hold on what there's bin
ladens that live in america
this seems really by the way let me let
me read this whole story so people get
the idea some of bin laden's
brother ibrahim bin laden has listed his
longtime builder mansion for whopping 28
million dollars ibrahim who's the older
half brother of the late terrorist has
owned the property for nearly
four decades this is a new york post
story since 1983 ibrahim purchased the
mediterranean villa style mansion for
1.653 million dollars in 1983
what would be roughly 5.5 million
dollars after counting for 38 years of
inflation but according to uh to the
listing he hasn't occupied the home
since 9 11 attacks
like osama ibrahim was one of 56
children born to the saudi
arabian construction tycoon muhammad bin
awad bin laden
muhammad served as the patriarch of
multi-billionaire bin laden clan a
family with long-standing businesses
ties to al-saud
royals adam gohan you were saying
something yeah well look
as i started reading the story the
beginning of it i was like hold on what
the hell are you talking about osama
milan has family that lives here in bel
air what the hell like what is going on
here
no that he hasn't occupied the home
since september 11th
and then you don't just go with the
headlines you dig a little deeper like
you said you can't
and i said all right he's got 56
siblings 66 children from 22
concubines and all right that that that
that makes it a little easier to i mean
you and i and i circle back to the
interview you did with nora bin laden
who i think is a big trump lady
it's just uh you know how they say the
apple doesn't fall from the tree
sometimes it does
i interviewed a guy yesterday i can't
wait for this interview to go live his
name is uh
what's his name amin amin and he was a
former al-qaeda member who became an mi6
spy
wow i mean it's a fascinating story
brilliant guy genius of a guy was
recruited by osama bin laden he was
there at one of the meetings when osama
bin laden sold him on the vision
of what they were going to be doing he
was part of the camp he worked with them
he was a one
he was a person he he says osama bin
laden came up and he says listen
you obviously don't have what it takes
to be one of those visionary leaders
that people follow
you just don't have that i said this is
what osama bin laden told
him i said why would he say that he says
because i had glasses on and i was small
and i was weak
and he wanted people that were strong i
said okay i said so what did he say you
could do he says well he knew i was very
well read he says i think you can make
bombs for us
so he said they taught me how to make
bombs that's the story and he became an
mi6 spy for uk telling on
everything he learned working with
pretty incredible that they kept the
last name like i feel like
if you if somebody in your family does
something that atrocious i think you
just got to go ahead well you know pablo
escobar's son
uh and and his wife changed their last
name and they went and lived in
argentina
pablo escobar's son's name is pablo
escobar
but he changed his name to sebastian
marroquin you're gonna have to switch
that one up you're gonna have to switch
that one up yeah
there's not too many made offs yeah or
hitler's not a lot of stalin's out there
yeah
it's probably not uh not a name you want
to yeah that kind of does make sense the
more i think about it you know you're
about sasha phenomenal point you just
made right there
so my dad tells me i said that so why
don't you guys name me sasha i said my
mom wanted me
sasha how did that idea come about and
she said you ever seen the movie
uh he said dr zhivago and in dr zhivago
the communist was
sasha my dad said never in a million
years will i name my son after communist
he named me patrick although most people
in the military told me you know your
real name is not patrick you look more
like a muhammad than a pantry
yeah i said i'm telling you it's patrick
they said you're lying to me did you get
a lot of hate in the
military of course i did but being a
middle eastern but you have to learn
to troll back and play with them instead
of being sensitive about it
that's a great game right there so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye